live and the Rich Eisen show studio
local boy making good here in Southern
California we've got Brian Ortega here
how are you sir I'm doing good now where
are you from you're from right around
here commit from the I call it the
harbor area right which is San Pedro
Carson Torrance area Wilmington so just
that the entire harbor area south bay
area and that's so you've grown up and
sent the center on the San Pedro area
and is that where you started yeah
seeing how you could perform absolutely
I was I was born and raised in the
projects of San Pedro and I decided my
dad decided put me in fighting to to
help me just be a better fighter and
pretty much that that area you know and
and that was it I fell in love and and I
just been in fighting in all types of
training in my life so who outside of I
guess your dad would be a role model for
you who did you say you know I want to
be this person as in terms of how they
are as a human or or success how about
both let's start with successful
successful was just any chance you know
especially the guys I like to really
like George st. Pierre how he conducted
himself as a champ you know he's
professional you never talked trash it
was always just you know he was he was a
professional and role models would you
have to be my dad you know your dad yeah
okay yeah my dad man you what did he
instilled in you brought yeah he just he
pretty much was always there for me you
know and even even when I was bad he
would teach me how to how to be bad in a
good way
I see if it makes sense no it does make
sense he's like if this guy's gonna be
doing this let me teach you how to do it
right well yeah he was just he was
always there men don't know you know no
matter what he's always been there and
supported me in anything that I did and
always wanted better for me and and now
that I am where I am he's proud well
you're coming off a first-round knockout
of Frankie Edgar at UFC 222 earned you
performance of the night how do you
think you stack up against max Holloway
who hasn't lost in quite some time I
feel good man I feel good he hasn't lost
in some quite some time and I've never
lost so I feel
this is a perfect chemistry for for a
war mm-hmm
you know you have two guys who are young
two guys real hungry one guy who's on
top of the mountain and one guy who
wants to throw them off you know for me
that makes a perfect concoction for you
know for fireworks I'll be honestly that
sounds way too nice Brian sounds like
you know you want to step up your your
anger level a little bit here but you're
not ready to do that as you can see no
man I'm pretty I'm pretty calm pretty
cool calm and collected so then what
what do you go through to get in the
ring to get into that it's simple for me
I don't have to I'm not one of these
guys that has to amped herself up they
have to tell themselves all these guys
gonna take food from you know like
everyone has their own tactics for me is
just lock me in there and when you lock
me in there I got to finish you simple
is that
whether it's pretty whether it's ugly
where there's nice I have an objective
and that's to finish the man in front of
me and I got to do it at all cost
but there is a switch in there there's a
switch my eyes change my coach told my
coach James Larssen tells me that my
eyes change I don't really see it but
mmm well yeah who's looking at your eyes
can see it too well but it's not but
you're saying you're not like
envisioning something you're not going
through something in your head no okay I
see the guy in front of me I know it's
about to be it you know it's gonna it's
gonna be war time in a matter of seconds
and and then the the the switch goes on
and and I get ready for war Brian Ortega
here on the Rich Eisen show you are
aware of how Frankie Edgar seats this
fight correct you were that how he sees
it yes
between you and Holloway whether he gets
the winner yes and yeah we police the
winner is going to be your opponent
that's okay is it people believe all
kinds of things I can't get in this
guy's I can't get in this I can't get in
the steel cage right now keep trying
okay so nothing I can do is you can make
you take a dolly and throw it through a
bus window no I'm not Connor ring okay
you've never even been that angry yeah I
have what don't say right now you can't
say right now no I mean I've been that
angry before men I've
what's caused you to be that angry
before your stuff in my life yeah
whether it's a street fight or whatever
you know the other side comes out but I
said unless we're fighting then then you
don't see that side mm-hmm now your
foundation let's talk about your
foundation and and how people can get
involved and what it is in support of
what is your foundation no the Brian
Ortega foundation is is pretty much be
the change you want to see in the world
yeah if I don't like the way someone's
treating a homeless guy I'm gonna treat
him the way I feel he should be treated
you know whether it's give him some food
whatever if there's a kid who's growing
up and similar things that I grew up in
and and he feels like there's no hope
give him hope if there's people just any
anyone who needs help
that's what the brown Ortega foundation
is about you know it's just to encourage
a lot of people who have the same like
mentality and to just go out there and
just do a little bit of good mm-hmm and
I feel like once once you know it's
gonna be contagious where everyone
finally sees that at least for me I
truly love seeing people happy I get a
kick out of it there's few people like
you know they say there's few people
like that I disagree I feel were when
this this kind of mold where everyone's
hating on each other and everything but
when for me it's like when I see a
little kid and I go to a hospital and I
see I'm happy that makes my day if I go
and I see a homeless or starving and I
take half of my sandwich and I gave it
to him he goes off
thanks man cuz I was starving I'm happy
so just little things like that and
imagine if you have that's just one of
me and I know there's a lot of me like
out like that out there it just it's not
broadcasted the world likes to see dumb
stuff so I'm here to just make a change
in that and kind of the good is gonna
make a different fight make everybody
who you come across better for having
met you with the exception of max
Holloway on the 7th of July even he
after this war that's our job after this
war he can help me help people ok
yeah but in terms of the fight what's
your prediction for this fight well I
got to finish him stand up choke him out
whatever I just got to finish him well
best of luck to you on your night in Las
Vegas
sending your endeavors and come back any
time you want to talk hey you know are
you a Lakers fan um I'm more I'm the
kind of guy that likes playing sports
doesn't like watching them okay so what
other sports you have then I do it all
man I surf a lot
I run a when my partner's myself we run
a clothing brand called black belt
surfing I could see what you're right
right now um we train fight surf skate
play basketball play baseball okay
uh I mean you name it man we're we're
not one-trick ponies we're good at
everything
well good to see you here you could
follow Brian Ortega on Twitter at Brian
T City yep good to see you here sir you
got a brine Ortega the contender for the
featherweight title of UFC 226 right
here on the Rich Eisen show the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience